Tricia is with us in Houston Texas hi
Trisha how are you um thank you for
taking my home sure Roget I hope um I'm
calling my mother passed away in 2014
and in 2017 my father started calling my
husband and I stating he needed extra
funds that he was behind on some items
so we finally talked him into allowing
me to take over his bills and try to put
him on a budget good and like a good
daughter I trusted what he told me and
found out that in the last month that
the 99% of the items like his credit
cards are in collections and I've never
had anything like that so I really don't
know how to address it and how to handle
that okay so he's he's in a mess and he
handed it all to you yes okay and so how
much debt does he have total he has
around $10,000 in debt people credit
cards and he has a fifty-two thousand
dollar line of credit against his home
what's the home worth it is worth about
a hundred and twenty and in fact he has
decided decided to sell it underneath us
for sixty five thousand so at underneath
you he was supposed to sell the house
and divide the funds that was my
mother's wishes between my sisters and I
for the value of the house and he said I
don't want it anymore and he's in the
process of selling it for 65 why he's in
debt and broke why is he giving it away
this is a very common question between
my sisters and I why not and as he lost
his mind sometimes I think yes how old
is he 73 yeah I'm calling him out okay
you want me to help you with this stuff
and your
being stupid you be a little bit more
gentle than that but not much
you have $120,000 a set here I don't
need your money but I don't need you
call me looking for money every month
and you don't sell $120,000 a cent when
you're broke 465 let's sell it for 120
pay off your stupid credit cards and get
you in a place where you can live off
the rest of that money dad I don't need
your money but I do need you to plug
your brain back in what then the devil
are you thinking yeah that'd be my
conversation with him and if you if
you're not gonna allow me to speak into
this I'm not gonna help you clean up
this other mess either so no you don't
mean there's something really whacked
here going on and you need you dig into
it get to the bottom of it I'm sorry
you're facing this but be strong with
him